ja es ist natürlich schon jetzt wirklich
massiv weil es in den letzten zwei tagen
hier passiert ist also am
samstagnachmittag wurde ja dann diese
neue zone tier vor für london und den
südosten englands verhängen
das bedeutet man konnte jetzt wieder gar
nicht mehr eigentlich raus man darf
sozusagen nur noch wieder sich zuhause
befinden und man man darf weihnachten
nur noch mit seinem eigenen haushalt
verbringen eben nicht wie vorher geplant
sich vermischen und die läden machen wie
dazu ist es wieder alles dicht und das
hat natürlich die leute massiv
verunsichert die stimmung ist
unterirdisch und gerade jetzt zu den
feiertagen wo natürlich alle sich
minimal gehofft hatten mit den familien
im kleinsten kreise irgendwie zu feiern
sind jetzt natürlich auch wieder
komplett erschüttert und widerlegt
worden auch und dieser neuen virus
mutation und den neuen zahlen
wenn man jetzt noch mit seinem eigenen
hausstand feiern darf wenn ich das
richtfest du wolltest eigentlich nach
deutschland hier mit seiner familie
feiern darfst das jetzt also nicht mehr
wie hast du diese nachricht aufgenommen
vor allem wie sieht dein weihnachten
jetzt aus du bist in london besitzer
fest und auch noch leider mit dem corona
virus infiziert wie wie sie in die
nächsten tage jetzt für dich aus ja ich
bin für mich persönlich ist es jetzt
auch ganz eine schreckliche und sehr
sehr herausfordernde situation weil wie
gesagt ich wollte eigentlich heute früh
nach deutschland fliegen um eine familie
zu sehen
jetzt weiß ich nicht mal wenn ich
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt wieder sehen
kann sind nächsten wochen weil es jetzt
ja dieses landeverbot gibt und ich
natürlich zusätzlich noch positiv
getestet wurde
das heißt für mich persönlich bedeutet
das dass ich jetzt erst mal zehn tage
hier in quarantäne alleine in meiner
wohnung 17 war mein mitbewohner jetzt
auch gestern das haus verlassen hat
nachdem ich nun positiv bin und man ja
dann logischerweise sich auch nicht noch
weiter dem risiko aussetzen möchte da
andere anzustecken und von daher würde
ich weihnachten allein
in london mit keinerlei perspektive
ehrlich gesagt verbringen wie sich das
jetzt in den nächsten wochen bessern
soll und das ist schon heftig geradezu
zu so einem fest was eigentlich ja was
schönes und positives sein sollte also
positiv im sprichwörtlichen sinn mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren